let's say that f of X is equal to the
natural log of X and we want to figure
out what the slope of the tangent line
to the curve F is when X is equal to the
number E when X is equal to the number E
so here X is equal to the number E the
point E comma 1 is on is on the curve F
of E is 1 the natural log of E is 1 and
I've drawn the slope of the tangent line
and so I've drawn the tangent line and
we need to figure out what the slope of
it is or at least come up with an
expression for it and I'm going to come
up with an expression using both the
formal definition and the alternate
definition and that will allow us to
compare them a little bit so let's think
about first the formal definition so the
formal definition wants us to find an
expression for the derivative of our
function at any X so let's say that this
is some arbitrary X right over here this
would be the point X comma f of X and
let's say that this is let's call this X
plus h X plus h so this distance right
over here is going to be H this right
over here is going to be the point X
plus h f of X plus h now the whole the
whole underlying idea of the formal
definition of limits is to find the
slope of the secant line between these
two points the slope of the secant line
between these two points and then take
the limit as H approaches 0 as H gets
closer and closer as H gets closer and
closer this blue point is going to get
closer and closer and closer to X and
this point is going to approach it on
the curve and the secant line is going
to is going to become a better and
better and better approximation of the
tangent line of the tangent line at X so
let's actually do that so what's the
slope of the secant line what's the
change in your vertical axis which is
going to be f of X plus h minus f of X
minus f of X over the change in your
horizontal axis and that's X plus h
minus X and we see here the difference
is just H over H and we're going to take
the limit of that we're going to take
the limit of that
as H approaches zero so in the case when
f of X is the natural log of X this will
reduce to the limit as H approaches zero
f of X plus h is the natural log of X
plus h minus minus the natural log of X
all of that over H all of that over H so
this right over here for our particular
f of X this is this is equal to f prime
of X so if we wanted to evaluate this
when X is equal to e then everywhere
where we see an X we just have to
replace it with an e this is essentially
expressing our derivative as a as a
function of X it's kind of a crazy
looking function of X you have a limit
here and all of that but every place you
see an X like any function definition
you can replace it now with an e so we
can see let me just let me just do that
whoops
I lost my screen here we go
so we could write we could write F prime
of e F prime of e is equal to the limit
limit as H approaches zero of natural
log we do in the same color so we can
keep track of things natural log of E
Plus H I'll just leave that blank for
now minus the natural log of e all of
that over H all of that over H so just
like that this right over here if we
evaluate this limit if we're able to and
we actually can if we are able to
evaluate this limit this would give us
the slope of the tangent line when x
equals e this is doing the formal
definition now let's do the alternate
definition the alternate definition if
you want to find if you don't want to
find a general function derivative
expressed as a function of X like this
and you just want to find the slope at a
particular point the alternate
definition kind of just gets straight to
the point there so what they say is hey
look let's imagine some other x-value
here so let's imagine some other x-value
this right over here is
point is the point x comma well we could
say f of X or we could even say the
natural log of X X natural log of X what
is the slope of the secant line between
those two points what is the slope of
the secant line between between those
two points well it's going to be your
change in Y values so it's going to be
natural log of X natural log of X minus
1 minus 1 through that red color minus 1
over your change in X values that's X
minus e x minus e X minus e so that's
the slope of the secant line between
those two points well what if you want
to get the tangent line well let's just
take the limit as X approaches e as X
gets closer and closer and closer these
points are going to get closer and
closer and closer and the secant line is
going to better approximate the tangent
line so we're just going to take the
limit as X approaches e so either one of
this this is using the formal definition
of a limit let me make clear that that H
does not belong part of it so we can
either do it during using the formal
definition or or the alternate
definition of the derivative